hey guys welcome to the Rubin Report I'm still Dave Rubin we've got
writer and BuzzFeeder Louis Peitzman
with us and comedian
and renaissance man John Fugelsang with
us
and let's get right to it john boehner
he's the speaker the house he's a very
very tan man
and guess what he is suing President
Obama that's right he has had a
with these executive actions that
basically the republicans have forced
President Obama to take
because they won't allow him to get any
legislation to his desk to sign
and now I they're saying he's
overreaching so bainer is
actually forming a lawsuit to sue the
president over this
and the present Obama is not too happy
about it we've got some video
you know the soon as a spot but what I
toll sticker better directly years
if you're really concerned about me
taken too many
executive actions
why don't you try get something done
through congress the majority American
people
wanna see immigration reform done we had
a bipartisan bill through the Senate and
you're gonna swap
here hi trial fix some parts of the
administratively
that are within my authority while you
are not doing okay so
just be very clear: what's happening
here the republicans are not giving him
any legislation to signs that he's
trying
to take power with which is within his
rights
even though I talk a lot about how I'm
not for the executive actions and I
believe in separation
a powers and all that but they're pretty
much giving him no choice he seems
pretty
is there for Obama that's actually
pretty personally think
I agree well he's right that it's a
stunt and it's got nothing to do with
him
its all about the fact that john bainer
knows how deeply the Tea Party hates him
and this is nothing more than a craven
plea to the Tea Party to respect him
by doing something disgusting Obama has
had
significantly fewer I executive orders
the president bush which never bothered
anyone
yeah and it's literally like 20 percent
yeah
you know this is but this is aging are
just whole thing he's got nothing going
he has no legislative agenda
no legislative agenda whatsoever and
this is why when they want to talk about
Obama having a low approval rating well
congress has a low approval rating than
media I
comedians like it by dollar 50 had a
consensus fun getting there
I suppose to John Mayer so this is all
look when when they were voting
last year on the speaker of the house
should be they were singing
several rather conspicuous protest vote
against
speaker bainer louie Gohmert actually
voted
forearm for once a space the lunatic Ted
Cruz
no not a cruise the Alan Webb which many
technicalities yeah
Alamosa so kids historian flushed itself
down the toilet
reported that a job at hand without a
job there yeah Gohmert voted for guy
who'd been voted out of congress to be
the speaker of the house
over a speaker bainer he knows how
deeply unpopular he is
the day's biggest ally was Eric Cantor
who wanted his job
this is John beaners desperation showing
through and it's not gonna make the Tea
Party I like him anymore
and that really did work after Eric
Cantor so before we get into too much to
the political leadership this did you
know that they can even sue the
president
doesn't seem like the worst possible
eckhard government so dysfunctional
and by the way a you could see the
present woman I'm seeing
I'm seeing better being desperate times
about me angry and I think the best way
to solve this is with reality television
hacer G-ten shell when I would
absolute support a stunt like that if I
can't watch it play out on TV
yeah is what do we do about this because
this is saying we talk about every week
on this that just the branches of
government no longer work
that Obama is being forced in the
morning they were kid not to sound like
a man in a room but they work if you
work at it
right but with the concert that we have
now just with did with that
republicans are being held hostage by
the tea party like it's just nothing's
working
so what do we do to make this work
instead going to EDI dick lawsuits
and forcing the president and to do
things that a lot of people don't want
to do an upcoming
well I mean this is Obama's Making Work
that's what he's doing this the American
people don't wanna sit around
you know complain about the government
they want the government to do stuff for
them
but it is in the interest that the GOP
to make government as weak as possible
they serve the CEO's the struggle our
country is never been
conservative versus liberal its
aristocracy bursa democracy
and a Disney interest %uh the upper 1
percent
the appoint a one-percent evil half
Iraqi government for working and I find
interesting the same people who are
trying to weaken government
here are complaining that other
countries your government is weak
I love aline is a tweeted earlier its
you know who is exactly what they do
day one they're getting exactly what
they want they want the gridlock they
want nothing to happen
because it government works that means
democracy works in a democracy works
that means the people are gonna run this
country and that is not in the interest
of these
vassals the Koch brothers so going to
your reality show point should we have
more cameras around
what's going on really analysis do
remember during the Obamacare debate
even present Obama said we will have
this all been to everybody will aired on
c-span
of course not if that happened I'd and I
think the Democrats don't wanna just as
much as the republicans the one
so really shouldn't we had not been as
me realize you were moaning people of
all I think that's pretty good idea
but should we are just more cameras
around so some other stuff is actually
true or at least a really well made
Netflix documentary
I mean a change I have mine on Romney
that and come out her hand action
thinking on there that I've got that the
documentary was metal baseball
up and how would have been more
interesting out to your eye to eye I
think the Supreme Court
should be on television I think student
I think classrooms
I think public school classrooms should
be on the internet I think executions
should be televised we're paying for it
I will if you televise executions use
seeded No the numbers on death penalty
sleep overnight
so you think you would go down I think
because I suggested it might actually go
people who go to church call themselves
Christians despite the fact that Jesus
quite clearly spoke out against killing
the center
he never mentioned birth control never
mentioned abortion never mentioned gay
people
its began about killing the center
rather specifically if these people saw
the murder that their tax dollars pay
for and by the way
I like that they don't consider it
murder if the state doesn't have to get
more big government a strapping died
when tabling poisoning in the death
right and doing it for our viewers yes
although sometimes the guy that's
actually doing the poisoning or the
electrocution really doesn't even know
because they have them by
taxpayers have a right to see as much up
what they pay for
as possible that doesn't jeopardize
national security yeah
are televised case actually know what
they're missing out on we did that the
next step in the gay rights movement is
televising a sec sorry guys that in a
minute there on porn sites
you I are you giving me a good segue
here because let's talk about seasons
and the gays because
Elton John has come out and said that
geez is
would be down with the gays that's right
we've got a little video
from the interview the gym think the
judge I mean the church do you think it
should
allow its clergy same-sex clergy to get
married
court and and and and i don't. by
Catholic priests have to be celibate
as crazy you know they these old and
stupid things I am
and the church hierarchy might be you
know
a up in arms about it the traditionalist
but times change we live in a different
time
China if Jesus Christ was alive today I
cannot see
him as the Christian personally he was
on the great person in the world
same this could not happen I'm he was
all about love and compassion
and forgiveness and trying to bring
people together and that is what the
church should be about
love and compassion and all that good
stuff could that be which eases was
really all about Louis
I I would say so yes I would also say
I'm at Taylor thing that struck me most
about this story was Elton John say he
wouldn't have a small wedding
that was not like I i'm shocked bandages
comments I was mostly shot by him saying
bad
you want to have a quiet small wedding
and not like a hologram Jesus actually
blessing the ceremony which is what I
would expect him to write I actually
really funny cuz you know he runs the
big Oscar party
here in West Hollywood after the Oscars
and its huge and over the top and
ridiculous but I just
yeah I mean I actually better than I
think fed now um
they're funny persons who who have the
same comment sent the same points about
Jesus teachings and
I'm house only match what we hear about
in the book religious right on a regular
basis
yet so John this is your wheelhouse to
this is one your favorite haunt me know
look I think Jesus would object Elton
John said listen concert I
what the new stuff I like the Leon
Russell out but do I have to wait three
hours to get to your side that guy
other boy of course he's right I mean
he's wrong about one thing that Jesus
was a Christian person Jesus
lived indicted you your arm by he's
exactly right about homophobia is an
insult to God there is no passage in the
Bible
say this that thirty-year trolls your
there is no
passage in the Bible you can use to
justify any kind of LGBT discrimination
90% of all the medicare some Romans
isn't about gay people
arm II know all the verses very well
there's nothing in the Bible to justify
it so he's exactly right about that
he's also weighed about the Catholic
Church in celibacy
the cat the first pope said Peter was
married all the principals ambitions
were married for over 1000 years
was it opens at the second in 1139 e di
main celibacy the law
to keep recent popes from leaving land
in wealth to their children
so that was not because sex is bad now
because Christ was a bachelor because
the church
was greedy which means married priests
are technically
the conservative point of view that's
quite fascinating and how it's all Greek
base
soon dealing the church in a long-term
actually kinda screwed itself with all
this crazy sex stuff and the repression
in the case that that it worked for a
while
for many hundreds of years at work but
now we're getting to the point where
that stuff doesn't fly anymore and it's
actually turning people
more against the religion of course to
know it always backfires mean looking in
to leave the country where
are because the Catholic Church being
there they had no contraception they had
very few
teaches me that anti-abortion one at the
bush rate skyrocketed
not the death from Wasilla crazy because
they had no teaching about how to have
have a conversation in these things the
more draconian laws are the harder it is
to kind of have a normal
a safe life attacks the tree supposed
divorce
you know and again birth control not in
the Bible this is the same
this wall is the same reason why we have
the laws apply to CAS it's not about
holiness it's about keeping your tribes
numbers up and they're becoming a third
world religion
and they're going into the third world
and saying your poverty is a gift from
God to get your reward in heaven
you can be developed this you're pumping
him out and the more more people you
have
were superstitious and agreed to keep
getting more babies the more
the more size your flock as and the more
you can police said flock
and its back it still works in the third
world its backfires big time in the
first world
yeah so units publicly supported number
right not be really care with people who
supported ok that's about the same
do you think when Elton John says I'm
like this does any heart or mine get
change occurs the people that are on
board you think that actually effect so
so somebody that i think is a believer
you think it actually hear that message
the burden is on them to explain why
Christ would oppose same-sex marriage
when he never said a thing against gay
people
and I could bore you with the you know
passages that I think prove that Jesus
had a pro LGBT
attitude the story the Roman centurion
whose whose
expertise with my house till my slave
and the apostles were so angry that we
know about the Romans historically
there under teenaged boy lovers on the
road yeah
the Greek the word is a slave in space
for beloved boy
so that explains why the apostles were
so furious Jesus
that he and why would a Centurion Avia
again I'm taking the story literally
yeah that's that's really wanted want
this and sure enough the Imperial
European occupying army seek out a
homeless
local jewish mystic the peeler to come
into his home
to heal a common slave explains why the
apostles were so outraged because Jesus
essentially blessed a gay Union yeah
John taking the high brosser Jesus had
abs that's proving a hacer una lowbrow
now is and also yeah let's just do that
more reality television more
fixation teasers abstract Jesus exploded
really insecure
he totally does I remember to left on
this
so you know this new pope has been kinda
down with the gays and he's been to a
sourdough
its till you get a lot of pressure but a
little bit early but not at the same
time so
but but basically he kind of has said
let's get away from
talking the talk better than any other
pope I'm waiting for the walk to get
walked
yeah I assume same yes the same damaging
bed
down it's easy to kinda be happy makes a
statement to go viral on Facebook
but I don't know if he actually has I
mean here to carry through the TV start
in any meaningful way
yeah I love the guy and hope it gets
really good food taster I
yeah hopefully he will poking you acting
like this on
you can't blame thanks I said that by
the three-day another sense
the try let's talk about Facebook have
you heard in this monstrosity this giant
company
that is stealing all your data you
signed up for those lies that feeling
I'm not so sure you know what they're
doing with your data they are actually
doing bizarre
scientific tests at to depress you yeah
that's right we've got some info
for one week in early 2012 Facebook
change the content makes in the news
feed
about seven hundred thousand users some
were shown a higher number
a positive post while others were shown
more negative posts the study found that
users were shown more negative content
were slightly more likely to produce
negative posts users in
the positive group responded with more
upbeat posts okay
so we all talk about this all the time
data and that we just give this step
away and we'd never read the Terms of
Service and weekly gas on everything
but now they're actually manipulating
things to alter
our mood am pretty sure nobody signed up
for that
at I keep pace but I talk about it
constantly on the show
that negative things make people feel
negatively its
saps monstrosity is this I yes it is
crazy the theory
that negative things that make other
negative things crazy
and how do you know if you want the
subject if you're already depressed all
the time like me
like I don't understand I'm they
probably would have left someone like
you out if they're out
a chat with him that I was part of the
experiment me feel a lot better about my
better behavior exactly I mean I'm
depressed by Mike distant cousins making
me play candy crush saga
so I million got worse ago okay so
should anyone be upset by this
really though because we sign up for
these things we know
we don't read the Terms of Service right
it's a fifty-page thing the just scroll
down click YES on
and then they're doing this to us but
it's a free service so do we have any
right
even to be upset we have a right to be
upset that they showed us things that
were depressing when we were using their
free service
that we signed up for we have a right to
be upset but we have any recourse
against them
it's it's it's their baby rector some
people are trying to get together and
pour some kinda lawsuit but
I'm sure that's not going to get you go
to a party voluntarily in the music bums
you out
your welcome to leave the I mean I'm
master I most sides do these things you
know when they have like two different
versions for different users and
in CNN different headlines for example
to see what look like on more you know
the old Dell testing us
yes just probably giving you more a few
high school friends having babies
to prather tonight does really bummed me
out but you know it's my choice to be on
Facebook into
for whatever reason befriend people
haven't seen in 12 years the acting as
ever find that the positive news
actually depresses you more than the
negative news you know to me like it
they there's some theory on this that if
you keep seeing your friends doing all
this cool stuff
by people just buy Instagram everyone's
food looks better than it actually is
and you think everyone's eating better
food than you so do you ever get more
depressed by the positive things that
you see people doing
than just the people who are suicidal
when it comes to Instagram I I'm really
torn between pictures other people's
food
and pictures /a girls feed on a beach in
for bodies of water
yeah acts were torn between those two
people areas but a
you know I believe it was a ni Chiru
said we hate it when our friends become
successful
know that was marcy and the header ask
cause
yeah I me know I i mean if its a
positive news in the world grade
yes positive news for my friends I if
their friends and I love it's great if
their friends I
secretly hate them you know that's my
problem in it your but I mean if that's
a good
period like that filegate Facebook just
had more pose hash tag blast
that probably had been more homicidal by
the end of the day I
are you guys with me in the general
thing I just had it with Facebook I just
don't like
anything that it's about now I only have
fan page so I'm not involved in
in all the my new show what's going on
with their
the feet and everything which is this
connectedness is
I'm just completely over and I said no I
disagree I love it I
yeah I love knowing the names of my
cousins hideous chilled I
I love being able to get back in touch
with the same guys who called me a
faggot to govern my hair in high school
yeah I you know being able to do that
and and but now you later here than it
being able to
being able to get you know which brat
pack member quizzes are you ten times a
day is in which we called
now I mean I I like Facebook I use
Facebook as a promotional tool is a
comedian
yeah I have a standard I have a fan page
I have I have the all profiles are used
to happen I have a private page for my
family were dispersed baby pictures so
Mike
cousins don't think I'm a leftist
monstrosity here so how do I get a life
you get what you put into it and I'm
I don't really get so sucked into with
that I'm getting my email
information we Tapson things like that
no Facebook gaps
no Facebook axe science and a so you're
doing it in a very controlled kinda way
how do you manage personal check your
facebook fanpage privilege does not
always have that are
that time I had actually know he dragged
me they I say that with all
do like grossness really no I mean I
love Facebook in the middle
on Twitter you know it's a mixed bag and
I feel like it's a great promotional
tool on you use it
as you need to use it and you block
people willingly I mean I have a bunch
of I had this problem where a lot of
them involve me in facebook
we don't really know why our but they do
yell at me and Chris have a language
and you talk about the Golden Girls
Aloud I do it we certainly know where
they came from but I do have a facebook
problem with harassment
communist make a job and a bit because I
feel like it's a the best way to handle
things but his much better with
harassment and Twitter though because
yes actually have to show your name and
identity in most people don't go to the
trouble of putting together a
an alias as they do on Twitter on
Twitter these these these coward
child men can come out and call you
names
yeah yet they're protected by their own
anonymity that doesn't happen on
Facebook I have a policy
the Twitter party which is I won't fight
with an egg if you're just a Twitter a
guy will not
you fight with them and no I don't like
going oh i don't realize I'm about I
read tweet I reach week the really
brilliant stuff that really funny stuff
and the really
I mean dumb stuff yeah you know check I
check their
check their follower count because it
fits in with 12 followers
no seeking getting these delay moore's
yet these guys went
these eggs with well I'm like he did
Twitter there's girls here what you
doing what if I'm like this
but I honestly I I think they can be
very instructive
and I think that you can use those
debates as away about
letting someone else hang themselves
creatively yeah arts a final thought on
this is there anything that would get
you to the point where you be willing
to actually get off facebook it likes of
the if you know they're doing
experiments on you
is there any point with which it would
just
you know the strong the camel's back
missus a now and many
really honest about it yourself problems
uploading missed my stop on Facebook
like
their its gonna say yeah are they do
anything with all this information even
if you're hiding it to the best you can
invest in Union Carbide they could be
big yeah they could debut no funding
baby seal clubbing trips I mean there's
a lot of things to get done that was
recovered a
see you after I hate him no lot of
things that can be done why would one
work
work want to withdraw my my my
membership but I i think that they're
smart businessman the creative fun
service
it is a great way to keep in touch with
relatives without having to actually see
them
and I think in that sense it's gonna be
around for a long time yeah all right
there you go
let's talk about cupcakes they are the
newest hottest controversy we always
have a controversy about something that
used to be okay now is cupcakes a
Seattle School is banning cupcakes
in elementary schools why are they doing
it well we've got some info for your
basically they don't want kids to be fat
that's already short-handed
so they are allowing food can only be
served act 3
classroom celebrations per year the
decision was based on nutritional
factors in economics it's not healthy
for a cupcake party to be prone
for every student on their birthday
because if you're in a class A 30 that
means you're adding thirty cupcakes the
year
which basically one cupcake every 10
days and I think that and not of
families can afford to send troops to
school for a birthday celebration
leading some students to feel slightly
left out so I guess maybe that line has
some validity at the making some kind eg
economic arguments or to make sense but
the idea that we're taking these
companies I
I get sugar we talk about give you wings
are all rubbish
yeah I mean I get I get all the stuff we
have a high fructose corn syrup in all
carvel separating ever again diabetes
and all this stuff
I get all that the reason go the reason
is
teachers unions know better than anyone
you don't give rooms at thirty kids
all got a hundred and expect to do your
job to tell the tale
yet so that's really what's going on you
they want to control those kids is
screaming little
im sitar perhaps it's disgusting they're
all hopped up on crack now you can says
the one father on the panel
we i mean i think is interesting they
said an article you're being heard
parents bringing other things like
erasers
which is a hilarious to me I guarantee
if I ain't going up had had a pair bring
in something that was inedible I would
have found a way to your hand hi I'm not
going to school having birthday parties
migraines a week and if there is also a
lotta kids are born in Somers was not
thirty
now I was born on Labor Day and my I'm a
Virgo
which means a lot to work but I'm worth
it and yeah
and the fact is that I won my first day
of school in first grade was my birthday
and I told the teacher it's my birthday
G but I was lying I never got a cupcake
party it wasn't until months later she
found 11 telling the truth I had a
retroactive 1i I was reparations
yeah it's a lot to me but no it there
are other practical ways you can give
bringing grapes you know like you can do
other things for par you can sing a song
or do something special to
to not teach kids for twenty minutes
right to your sort of down with the
general idea this
I'm really crazy sugar why did you not
me it's that it's not it's not because
I've the nutritional factor they're not
afraid that one cupcake party or even
thirty cupcake parties
is gonna cause obesity I'm more worried
about the kids are eating at home
low-income families can afford a healthy
meal you know
I was in mississippi making this film
for PBS and you know it so many
communities there's no
grocery stores in rural America and poor
families get all their food from the
dollar store
where the gas station which is all
process that it's not the that's not yet
that's not the school's responsibility
is all about sugar
and hop double crank its okay so if it
is about that do you still think you
lose something by not having that like I
think back to my elementary school days
those are great like that somebody in
common with the cupcakes everyone but
you lose something if we don't let kids
celebrate the way
key guess what the sugar when they're
adults to so I get you try and
set summit leaders at the deal with
hatch right so I get it but leaving them
losing something like
do just losing saying about growing up
if you can eat freaking cupcakes in
school
yes the cupcake you might look it will
find when he cut it anyway
I mean I'm not saying anything but the
term argument that's kinda people who
are going to get girls say but I I just
feel like
happy to happen regardless maybe have
one party among freshmen born in that
month and you have a
at condensed cupcake in and you can have
it at
you know at 3 p.m. is it having an open
day and using it Solutions has been on
the studying cupcake great see you want
the cupcakes the teachers union would
say you know what give them a cupcake as
they're leaving school he had to hang up
a happy to see one small tiny victory
for teachers
somewhere in America but I think a very
practical solution is
the end if every month you have you
taken one hour
the and every month and have your
cupcake party for all the kids who had a
birthday that month
that way the poor kids aren't singled
out for more shaming if they can bring
in cupcakes you just do for every kid
with a birthday in March
we're doing it and we're doing it in the
thirty minutes before we put you on the
bus
I right that doesn't bode well for the
bus drivers
know if they have a very powerful union
do compared to compare to do with the
sugar high in
and only right they can just lock them
in the basement and do what they want
with them
you guys they were it were never had
like a bounce back against
this health conscious thing that we are
going on right now because we are
talking about it so much
that I do them beer that we're gonna
have this weird thing where suddenly
everyone's gone 1e awful some fear an
iPhone apps I get the best dollar
scenarios chameleon-like
spoon yet you think you'd be happy
ireland obviously that's a that's a
problem to you and I i feel like
we've we may be a little teachers and at
times I don't know I'm not raising a
child I'm also
are making my own poor dietary choices
Ralph so I don't now allow some
but is with you like the done thing as
you just said like it's to me so you
know every time with their substituting
somehow the gun sales go up
yes and I think that's partly what's
happening here we keep telling people
eat well and then everything shows
that they're getting worse is there
somewhere you what is it with the only
way to stop a bad man with a cupcake in
agreement that was amazing with an
equaliser type 2 diabetes can be
you know and I think unfortunately it's
gonna take you know it for me as a child
took sitting next to my grandfather with
lung cancer holding his hand when he
died
for me to know I was never any insect
take cigarettes yeah and I think
a lotta kids gonna have to see the
suffering of their parents and
grandparents
having an unhealthy lifestyle to really
realize it and even then they might not
because
with the drug and comfort food is really
nice way
above freezing something that would it
really is unhealthy habits
and it's not about changing diet is
about changing habits and that's a lot
harder
yeah that's why we talk about this on
the show because we're trying to get a
little
a little information across I've course
Im gonna still
eat cupcakes openly and freely according
to the Bureau of Labor Statistics
there are about 3.6 million people
who are at or below the minimum wage
there working at or below the minimum
wage
and up where the create a couple grass
on a synagogue pretty interesting
political
okay so who works at the minimum wage
teenage boys 10 percent I think that
make sense your first job cut grass
you know do in other newspapers there's
a newspaper boys that's what I did
adult women this one's crazy at minimum
wage almost half
those people are women adult women
teenage girls 14 percent
adult man 20 7.5 percent
now here's the fascinating part so 34
percent of these people who are at
minimum wage
have some college or an associate's
degree that seems incredibly high
7 percent have a bachelor's degree or
higher
I 28 percent less than high school so
that I think make some sense
and a 31 percent are high school
graduates
so this there's some interesting numbers
you some I think kinda surprising and
some
not too surprising but the the education
one is the scary one
me i mean the people that are going to
college and still working
minimum wage the scary number yeah I
mean
stay in school you going to working in
which job is not the best encouragement
the right that they're not helping now
the scariest number
which was it was on those grasses that I
believe it's 56 percent
other minimum wage earners are full-time
workers
and more than half a minimum wage
earners provide
most the income for their households
yeah
we have to decide if ur gonna live in a
society where person can work
full-time and still live below the
poverty line but these graphs to show a
very valuable because the want to do
most insidious arguments against raising
the minimum wage which a decent society
would do
eyes least we could do after destroying
unions which built the middle class
is that %uh they're all kids do in
summer jobs their starter jobs in S and
90 S
it's simply not the case so I assume
both you guys are on board the Seattle
idea
the fifteen dollar minimum wage are
going to cupcakes
and rather at that church address the
one to pay people in cupcakes going back
to an earlier
well yeah but I mean that's a separate
issue the week we're taping this of
course is the week that LA that
California's raise the minimum wage from
eight dollars to nine
San Francisco its 1074 an hour and if
you adjust for productivity
I and inflation the minimum wage today
should be twenty one dollars an hour in
Australia raised
there's to sixteen dollars an hour
unemployment went down
right it's gone up since then because
I've mining closer's by I
all the same doomsday predictions were
made and they were all prevent falls
every time they'd ever tried to raise
the minimum wage going back to henry
ford
instituting the five dollar-a-day wage
for his workers on
on the line at the Ford factory in a all
said this will crush the economy kill
jobs
it's never true because if you're
employees have more money they're
spending more money in your community
and it drives the economy the middle
class
are the job creators and if we're all
gonna be low wage slaves
eventually there will not be high enough
walls for the 1 percent
in their gated community yes you know we
did a story in December about
literally at Walmart because they pay
their employees so poorly they were
taking donations
at Walmart for their own employees but
we must deals
well that's the thing with wal-mart is
its price is so nice you pay from twice:
are you know there I get subsidized
there are some stores were up to eighty
percent
Walmart workers run snapper some kinda
public assistance so you're paying for
those low prices
when you're there buying your non
american-made crap and you're paying for
it again every April
of when you're paying your taxes and
subsidizing and that the sixteen years
at the Walmart fortune control as much
well that's the bottom forty million
americans
are that's disgusting and it's not
conservative in its not sustainable
and it's not same yes so when we hear
all those numbers were what are we
supposed to do
because it's not change this is all
getting worse well what do you think we
can do actually to
to change the trend USA for actual
solution like some kind of resolution
yeah I mean number on logic into the
argument
failures is up rare rearm no I mean I
think we're in the middle age makes
absolute sense I mean you have action
figures to back it up with which is
you know always act funny movie about it
sa mga
unfair you can prepare yeah I mean is
there really a question about this than
I think Braun agreement here
yeah why do you think women make so much
less than men still
you even in the white just said exactly
but even the white house this week they
show that the average man at work in the
white house right now
I think makes eighty seven thousand
dollars per year and the average woman
is making about 77,000 I get it there's
people a different jobs in there might
be some reason but what he did now
is it still women are making less it's
almost like there's like a disparity
between
one man may calm were made on a broader
scale
so it matches the White House I would
say it's not just the white house near I
want is a national problem may be unfair
to the white house you know women make
less because
that's what everyone's agreed to yeah
and when everyone stops agreeing with it
it'll change
but you know you want a real solution
get money into politics someone's
Saturday Russian this is the only way to
start it
find a way to get money out of politics
look I'm not a liberal an eisenhower
republican
okay and why was the middle class a
strong in the nineteen fifties
everything Republicans hate now
strong union involvement yourself a
favor look as in nineteen fifty-six
eisenhower reelection posters it's
all about Republican support unions when
people have more buying power
you have a stronger middle class and the
rich do better to infrastructure
spending like the interstate highway
plan
on add socialism like the GI Bill and a
more progressive taxation rate the
Richard never pay lower taxes and
seventy years then today this is all
fixable
man-made policies goddess into this
income quality mess and the policies
gets outta out so it's not cheeses
that's gonna get us
crash look if we had a government based
on Christian values I would be kind to
the poor kinda sick
kinda prisoners and that Star Wars got
there you go well pretty much everything
ever deal on this showing everything
using the news constantly
all is about money in politics to
actually go check out what that back
Dhaka are at Walmart Korea by the New
York Times has put together a composite
ranking up where americans are healthy
and wealthy
or where they're struggling and the
cyclic graph okay to the time came to
this conclusion by looking at six data
points for each county in the United
States may include
education median household income
unemployment rate disability raid
life expectancy and obesity alright so
by where you doing worse the more read
her the more are injured get
are the places you doing work so I the
South
not new in that well the tiny orange dot
by New York City at a movie theater over
there is the Bronx are not doing that
well in the Bronx I
Northern California I was surprised not
doing as well as I would have thought
now we're in So Cal be here and we're
doing okay
I but again the saudis by far the worse
the Midwest seems to be okay
a Florida I thought was kinda
interesting because the beaches
all are in good shape but if you're in
the middle of our to you're not new in
too well is there anything the middle of
our Derby maybe the beach is a hundred
years exactly Miami by the time we
finish the show could be
plan example your body will be a coral
reef the time even if the shoe yeah
exactly
um Joseph right there that it's the
highest concentration of doing worse
right in the heart of the voting against
their own interests belt okay a reason
alabama won for Romney and you're
looking at it right now
yeah so what's going on in that in that
are injured area
Luis can you gain color-blind to
actually can see this matter
I just trust me I
it's not doing too well in South days no
I thought that pretty really interesting
I was in shed that they include obesity
um in there and because unemployment the
city and everyone else was in there
arm but it seems very subjective I'm
always think about these things in terms
of like
my life Thomas office of a person social
thinking alike in Los Angeles being a
piece a lot harder than I like it is
in in some others blue place in the
midwest right
and the same does my personal opinion
yeah I'm with you don't think there's a
connection
between happiness and gay marriage
because apparently by that
map it looks like there's some
connection the places where gays are
okay
there's something ways I okay I mean
there's lotsa states where
wherein marriage equality has come about
because I've activism by
a morally awakened populace and other
states where judges just said no and
whether you like it or not so I don't
they don't think it's me as crazy
activist judges Williams
radically doing things that are you help
people you're an activist judge if you
help corporations aristocrats I
factory but i i do think that that on in
many cases you know that you know in a
more progressive place where you have
if you get the people abroad about
marriage equality the same people %uh
probably what about a higher wage
less income inequality and therefore
more happiness its wide Denmark is much
happier than we are
and why the American dream really should
be called the Scandinavian dream
because they enjoy a much higher
standard of living less income
inequality
and i'd you know no one goes bankrupt
ever
trying to pay for health care but are
they not is Priya's is in that
they're more free than us no I'm just
yeah think
I some so what made this is rather have
a broader than because there was one
that I thought was particularly
interesting there
wyoming they're pretty happy in wyoming
there's a
17 yeah and they're so is that we're
doing really well so Wyoming hopefully
if you
if you need to look at a map by looking
at this to figure out why I mother in
the middle upper love to see when North
Dakota looks like in five years because
the fracking economy is gonna change the
entire economic make up the whole state
and you can go to a place that was a one
stop sign town a year ago and make six
figures now driving a truck up there
and fracking will change the entire
economy of north dakota
wreck so you make a lot of money through
fracking but your water might be
exploding
I guess that could be a press over if
your water explodes in your face even if
you're in a big bet the house
but I wouldn't be too happy me doing
worse dollar had a fire going on your
director so it might suddenly get better
and then when the exploding water comes
then it'll get when there's something
the factors tutor to back into the same
is it was a very
it's very interesting just and its
complete picture the I means
so Wyoming that's why I think Wyoming
interesting one because there are so few
people there
yet they seem Paso is that partly it
there
Highlanders chain East drop in the rate
I get busy so that's why happiness is
gonna they're not have this gene is this
senator
I can't think about possibly more
perfect way to end it
John lewis thank you guys their twitter
is our right down below and we will do
this again next week
don't forget to comment like you too
that Facebook thing I love napping so
yeah at Twitter Instagram
pager is I love your show dates creature
die like having you guys I'm so I
world would do it again next week thank
you
up